the top story is live from the Sky News
City Studio
banking stocks continue to fall in the
wake of the rescue of Silicon Valley
Bank despite assurances from President
Biden
UK job vacancies down again as the
chancellor prepares to announce plans to
get people back into work
a dangerous road China hits out at the
UK us and Australia over their submarine
deal
why geothermal power could be the next
big thing in UK energy production
plus the Malbec dollar why wine
producers in Argentina are being offered
a preferential exchange rate
foreign
[Music]
good morning this is Ian King live in
hour of business and economic news from
the Heart of the City or Bank stocks in
the United States continue to fall
overnight in the wake of the rescue of
Silicon Valley Bank shares of some of
Japan's biggest lenders also tumbled
despite President Biden's assurance that
the banking system is safe well let's
have a look now at the market reaction
in some detail and a sell-off in banking
stocks on Wall Street last night in the
wake of Silicon Valley Banks failure saw
giants Wells Fargo and City Group fourth
by both seven percent a piece that was
followed overnight by sell-off in
equities in the asia-pacific region led
by the Banks Tokyo fell by more than two
percent with some of the big banking
stocks including Sumitomo and Mitsubishi
ufj Falling by more than seven percent a
piece they're also reverses in Hong Kong
Shanghai Mumbai and in Sydney with the
main index in South Korea off by more
than two and a half percent well in
Europe markets have tried to Stage a
rally this morning thus far though you
can see uh the movie Milan in negative
territory right now ago again the banks
are under under a spot of pressure the
Swiss lender Credit Suisse is currently
down by some five percent while the
Swedish online investment platform
nordnet is off by nearly four percent
we're here in London the ftse 100 is in
negative territory right now off just
over a third of one percent with uh the
financials again doing the damage the
leading Blue Chip Faller this morning
right now is the life and pensions Group
Phoenix which had its results out
yesterday the shares off by three
percent right now well as you can see
the lender's coming under pressure again
Standard Chartered off nearly two and a
quarter percent HSBC off nearly another
one and a half percent there are some
ftse gainers right now they're led by
BAE Systems and Rolls-Royce both are up
as they're seen as winners from the
orcas defense pact for which further
details were provided last night well
outside the ftse financials again coming
under pressure including virgin money
and TBC Bank while the broker TPI caps
chairs are off eight percent that is on
a look at that that's TBC Bank you can
see on screen their TPI cap the to deal
a broker off some eight percent right
now they've got a trading update out
this morning on the foreign exchange
markets well this time yesterday I was
telling you about how the dollar had
sold off overnight uh it clawed back
some of those gains a little earlier on
as you can see there so currently
Sterling off a fifth of one percent
lower against the Greenback uh Sterling
more or less unchanged against the Euro
The single currency meanwhile off a six
of one percent right now against the US
dollar as for the oil price well that
has weakened uh appreciably uh last
week's soft Chinese inflation data has
revived concerns over likely demand from
the country this year barrel of Brent
crude will currently set you back 79.20
about that is off by nearly two percent
on the session joining me today is Janet
Murray she's head of market analysis at
Brewing dolphin Janet morning to you
um obviously there's a lot of uh concern
about the banks but it's important to
stress that this is not a sort of
contagion situation like we saw in 2008
this is individual Banks being picked
off by investors because of individual
quirks in their business models
hi good morning yeah thanks for having
me yes uh that's that's what we believe
we think this is a unique case because
of the business model of svb and the
fact that the risk management is a
pretty bad at the bank where they didn't
really manage their assets which results
in a loss and people are very worried
and that's why they make the exit but we
don't think that it is a systemic
problem and the fact is that we can uh
the Federal Reserve and the treasury
they have problem with a plan to
basically backstop the depositors and
also provide emergency lending facility
to any banks who may need it so they
don't need to actually fire sell any of
their undervalued assets so you know
this actually prevents further contagion
and systemic risk but I think markets
are just very nervous given it is still
early stages of this debacle
you say Janet then the likes of Wells
Fargo and Citigroup which as I say sold
off by more than seven percent is this
sell-off being overdone in some cases
yeah I think that that could be the case
because I think as I mentioned investors
are just very nervous about uh the
banking system and the Financial Risk
out there I think also the reason why is
because the profitability of the banks
is being challenged well as we know High
interest rates usually benefit Banks but
you know what we have seen is that they
haven't really fully passed on the
interest rate Rises but as interest
rates rise further you know people are
going to question and people will try to
move their money elsewhere to find the
highest interest rate available so I
think this really highlights this
challenge going forward and also the
fact that you know Regulators are likely
to be more stringent going forwards
given the risk and I think the uh
dampening in sentiment is likely to
curtail lending in the sector which
ultimately you know made ultimately to a
slow economic environment
really good point you make that because
obviously one of the problems at Silicon
Valley was that uh it had a lot of
deposits tied up in U.S treasuries which
have obviously fallen in value
substantially over the last 12 months
none of the uh stress tests that we've
seen from central banks around the world
have focused on interest rate risk it's
been more on things like uh recessions
and falling house prices
I mean the interest rate is always a
very important component of uh the
stress test
um the fact is the Silicon Valley that
is outside of the stress testing system
because it has deposited uh under 250
billion uh it is considered as not a
systemically important bank but if you
look at the larger Banks out there
actually you know most of the banks in
the UK will be subject to these really
strange and stress tests so
that's why you know generally the
financial system is healthy it's
resilient it's just these Regional and
smaller banks that are really under
pressure and scrutiny at the moment now
as you pointed out uh markets are now
re-evaluating the prospect of uh
interest rate Rises and the pace and
trajectory of them is it possible that
they're just overdoing this ever so
slightly
yeah I think so the market moves happen
very extreme actually in the past two
days which is understandable
um because of the uncertainty as I
mentioned basically markets have kind of
priced out uh possibility of an interest
rate increase in the March meeting in
the US which I mean it could it may well
be the case depending on today's
inflation data and also the development
in the next week or so but ultimately
the US still has an inflation problem
right
um inflation is still going to be above
well above Target for the rest of this
year and it is very unlikely for the
Federal Reserve to just pause purely
because of this stress which by the way
they have tried to backstop already so I
think there is uh some extreme reaction
in the bond market which leads to this
extreme re-evaluation of interest rate
expectation which may maybe uh again
reassess in the next next week's
okay Janet good to see you this morning
thanks very much indeed for joining me
job vacancies across the UK have fallen
for the eighth period in a row as
companies appear to be holding back on
hiring or tomorrow the chancellor is
going to be laying out his plans to try
to get people back into work in his
spring budget well according for the
office for National statistics the
number of job vacancies fell by 51 000
from December to February to 1.1 million
meanwhile
unemployment remains steady at Jan in
January 3.7 that was the same as uh the
previous month and only a slight
increase from a low not seen since
1974. but joining me now is our business
correspondent gurfrey nawan gurpre
welcome to you I mean vacancies have
fallen but I'm in the labor market
remains incredibly tight yeah 3.7 it's
still uh pretty low by historic
standards
um and as you said redundancies they are
rising vacancies they are falling the
unemployment rate is steady at 3.7 but
we expect all of that to start feeding
into that unemployment rate it's
expected to start climbing now the bank
of England expects a peak of about 6.5
that's a lot higher as you just said
than it has been uh historically but
perversely the bank of England is
actually looking for signs of weakness
in the labor market because when the
labor market is running too hot when
wages are rising uh too quickly it puts
pressure on inflation and the bank of
England is trying to get inflation down
and it's already at a 40-year high and
is in double digits but pay growth in
the economy is slowing figures today
from the office for National statistics
showed that pay growth has slowed and as
I said slack is building in the economy
not only is unemployment Rising but
economic inactivity is coming down after
the pandemic a lot of people checked out
of the labor market altogether they may
have taken early retirement or they
stopped looking for work because they
felt that they were too unwell to work
but they are starting to come back into
the labor market and the government
really wants them to start looking for
work again expect to see some policies
in the budget to that effect but for now
I expect the chancellor Jeremy Hunt is
pleased to see the economic inactivity
is starting to come down because it
should take some of the pressure of pay
growth and in turn inflation
all right goodbye thanks for that
Sky News wants to hear your thoughts on
the budget will the Chancellor's plans
make a difference to your finances you
can contact us on 0208 167 2200 to be
part of a special program the budget
you'll say taking place tomorrow night
at seven o'clock here on Sky News I'm
going to be doing an online q a tomorrow
on the budget as well so if you've got
any questions for me you can submit them
on our digital platforms
now China has hit out at the U.S UK and
Australia over their pact to create new
nuclear-powered submarines saying they
have gone further down a dangerous road
the plum will deliver nuclear-powered
submarines to Australia as it seeks to
counter Chinese activities in the
Pacific Ocean for the first time ever it
will mean three fleets of submarines
working together across both the
Atlantic and Pacific keeping our oceans
free open and prosperous for decades to
come
Australian United Kingdom are of two
America's most stalwart and capable
allies our common values our shared
Vision more peaceful and prosperous
future unite us all across the Atlantic
and Pacific
for more than a century the SE we've
stood together to defend freedom and
strengthen democracy
and also mentioned shares of both ba
systems and Rolls-Royce upright now
leading gainers on the ftse 100 this
morning on that news last night that
extra detail time for some other
business news stories now and
Sainsbury's is paying 430.9 million
pounds to take control of a property
company that owns the freeholds of 26 of
its supermarkets the grocery giant had
always owned 49 percent of Highbury and
Dragons since it was created 23 years
ago it's now taking full control among
the stores owned by hybrid Dragon
include sites at Derby Doncaster
Gloucester Guildford and Norwich well
Sainsbury's said the entity is being
acquired had generated pre-tax profits
of 110.4 million pounds during their
most recent Financial years
the owners of two of the UK's remaining
nuclear power stations have confirmed
plans to extend the lives of the sites
EDF and centrica said the Hisham 1 and
Hartlepool nuclear power stations would
now close in March 2026 that's two years
later than previously forecast wahisham
1 and Hartlepool were both open 40 years
ago and when EDF and centrica bought
them in 2009 were due to end generation
in 2014. EDF said that as well as
helping the UK reduce its use of
imported gas the decision would mean
that 2 000 skilled jobs at the two sites
would be protected for a further two
years
and the merchant banking group close
Brothers has reported a sharp drop in
half year profits after raising
Provisions against loans it does not
expect to be repaid in full well the
bank which also owns the well-known City
Market maker winter flood Securities
reported an adjusted operating profit of
12.6 million pounds for the six months
to the end of January that was down from
129.8 million pounds in the same period
a year ago and reflected an additional
provision of 114.6 million pounds to
cover possible losses on the loan book
at novitas a litigation funding business
that it bought six years ago shares of
close Brothers which has almost 3
million business customers are currently
off by some four percent
now it's more than 75 years since the
expression export or die was first
coined but evidence comes today that UK
businesses which do indeed trade
internationally are outperforming those
limited to domestic trade well that
comes via the latest Santander trade
barometer which reveals that 59 of those
companies trading internationally have
seen an uptick in their performance
during the last year compared with just
45 of those doing business solely in the
UK will joining me now to talk about
this is John Carroll he's head of
international at Santander UK John good
to see you this morning I guess this all
students to be a surprise given that the
UK economy is growing more slowly than
some of its International peers no it
shouldn't and I think the key point this
is 15 surveys in a row we're
internationally trading smes have
outperformed the domestic counterparts
but also crucially a more optimistic of
growth in in the future but they also
are very clear in terms of what their
obstacles are so like all companies it's
basically access to Skilled staff it's
the cost of living but also four
specific areas getting access to New
Markets dealing with local regulation
the cost of transports but crucially as
well that skill set to better trained
internationally but we also now starting
to see some interesting geographical
Trends in this survey the EU now is the
top market for growth and India has
replaced China as the main market for
Asia that's very interesting I mean
presumably that's partly because China
was shut down for most of last year yeah
I think it is the Chinese aspect is is
quite an interesting one so obviously
it's normal that over three years have
been locked down that you would lose the
interest but it's gone from fifth to
13th in terms of growth but we also
asked for the first time the companies
are you dependent on China for your
supply chain if you're in the
manufacturing sector it's 58 retail
wholesale is 70 so half of those
companies are looking to diversify away
from China but only three percent for
example return wholesale want to
completely diversify which shows how
difficult it will be to completely
disentangle yourself from China That's
fascinating because I mean that's very
interesting because you do hear a lot of
talk about countries like Vietnam a lot
of uh activity being displaced to from
China what you the the problem you've
got for certain companies is it's been
the 30 years of China setting up a
really deep local infrastructure system
both in terms of ports and roads but
also in terms of Staff the Western
companies out there have spent 30 years
training the staff to replace it
overnight it's not going to be easy
which is why I think Richard said
there's a need for a robust pragmism
with with China because you won't be
able to completely disintegle yourself
from the country I mean India is a
notoriously difficult Market to crack
there's all sorts of protectionism in
there but I mean from what you're saying
it sounds like UK companies are giving
it a go well I was just out there last
week and we've sort of seen three broad
opportunities for for India the first
one when we took 14 whiskey and Gene
companies out there there's an
interesting an interesting stat that
each year the number of new consumers
who reach the legal age of consumption
for alcohol in India is the same as the
population of Australia so we took those
14 companies out there three or each of
them have three new potential contracts
as well but we're also seeing in terms
of tech companies so India's making a
real play for for essentially getting
tech companies to set up in India there
are one million new engineering
graduates every year in India and so the
tech companies there we're helping them
set up we've got links with specialist
HR firms to enable them to to use as an
extension of their Workforce and of
course as you say in areas such as
routine wholesale Indian companies are
now looking to be an alternative Source
but we're also helping the UK companies
here in terms of getting that validation
so that actually can be confident that
these companies are to have the right
conditions as well what are your sort of
golden tips for UK companies looking to
strike out into India well I think be
crucial about where the demand is so as
I say if you are looking to sell it
could be anything from whiskey to uh to
speed cameras which are in demand
um do not try and do things that India
is trying to make themselves so if
you're looking to export find those
areas which can't be produced locally if
not find those areas where you can
actually set up in India and work with
the local States and the local countries
to expand now you mentioned that the EU
is uh obviously uh still pretty
important for UK companies which
countries in particular I'm assuming
it's France France and Germany are the
other two countries and interestingly we
asked um this the survey was done the
week of the Windsor agreement and we
asked the companies how the Northern
Ireland protocol was affecting them over
half said it was a material issue so
that will be a positive I think this
this agreement but still one-third of
companies are having to deal with a
trading ramp which is worse than pride
and brexit so there will be a need to
continue to help these companies
navigate those domestic regulations
which is what we're trying to do on our
own platform very good John good
transfers you've got in the air Cricket
in when you went to India lost so it did
I tried it I tried Ian I'm still waiting
for the ashes this year well we'll see
you there
uh well we hear a lot about onshore and
offshore wind and nuclear as major
sources of low carbon energy in the
future there is rather less discussion
in the UK about geothermal power even
though it's a major energy source in
countries as diverse as Iceland the
Philippines New Zealand Kenya and El
Salvador but that may be about to change
geothermal engineering limited has just
secured 50 million pounds from investors
to build the UK's first deep geothermal
power plant at the United Downs
industrial site near Red Roof in
Cornwall well its backers include the
private Equity Firm kerogene Capital
Who's chief executive Jason Chang joins
me now live from Hong Kong Jason welcome
to you uh if all goes well when would
this site open
I am thanks for the science that you've
been uh
uh out at um corner for a while it's
been already drilled and so with our
investment we'll be able to start
producing energy next year into the grid
we'll also be trialing lithium green
lithium production later this year and
we'll also be in position to secure
a heat project in outer out of Cornwall
for the langar new project which is
going to deliver heat to potentially now
3800 homes so this is all happening very
soon
what are the potential obstacles to the
site opening what are the big things
that you're going to have to overcome
right well all the Committees already in
place so we're ready to go and the
financing was really the last part right
and what makes Cornwall such an ideal
place to to generate geothermal power
well geothermal has a huge potential
across the UK
um
I think as we mentioned in in the
release the UK is sitting on abundant
geothermal resources predominantly heat
enough potentially to carve the entire
UK's residential demand out of Cornwall
we have in particular a hot spot which
enables geothermal power to also be
produced in addition to heat
and I'll gather this particular site is
is quite propitious because it's
adjacent to a big supply of lithium
where there's lithium mining going on
there too
absolutely so on testing we found that
we've got one of the highest
concentrations of lithium in Europe so
we'll be testing uh that later this year
with a dle a direct lithium extraction
pilot
and uh in terms of the skills base in
Cornwall do you are all the workers
there that are needed for this project
to gain momentum
absolutely we've been blessed in the UK
with having a deep amount of skills
within the energy sector and UK also has
historically quite a large oil and gas
industry which enables quite a lot of
subsurface expertise and the team has
been out at Cornwall for some time and
so we do have enough labor resources to
be able to do what we need to do
not much you say the UK is a market
right for uh this kind of energy why has
the UK not really made the most of its
geothermal resources compared with
countries in Europe
hmm well I suppose geothermal while the
potential's been there the
decarbonization of heat and energy
security have only really been on the
agenda uh very recently and so now I
think we're looking at ways to
decarbonize heat which is not uh which
is not been a focus geothermal in the UK
is predominantly a heat technology and
as you know in the UK peaches around 40
of the UK's energy consumption and
around a third of uh GHC emissions so
with Net Zero targets it's now firmly on
the agenda and as a result I think
there'll be a lot more focus and
attention
I'm probably going to ask you to divulge
your trade secret here Jason but uh what
sort of return on Capital would you hope
to make out of this investment
right
well I won't be able to talk it
specifically about returns uh but what I
can say for example on in the continent
somewhere like the Netherlands uh under
the government's master plan there they
target a 15 return that the government
underwrites and so we'll be looking at
something in a similar magnitude
ah far from shabby Jason gotta leave it
though I'm afraid good to talk to you
this morning thank you
thank you
still to come here on Ian King live why
the UK economy might be doing better
than expected as business confidence
which is its highest level for a year
don't go away
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
they have breached the road there is a
lot of forecasting fired all around us
[Music]
this is an absolute Carnival kind of
atmosphere out here for prime minister
modi's types of Victory
these students have to find the
privately orders and now they're going
to be arrested we aim to be the best and
most trusted place for news the roads
have been inundated the only way out is
to get people by boat
this on any given day would have been
bustling with people but today it's
absolutely deserted I'm Neville Lazarus
and I'm Skye's reporter based in Delhi
[Music]
welcome back now the January GDP figures
published last Friday beat City forecast
just one of a number of pieces of
evidence recently that the UK economy
may be doing better than expected but
supporting that is the latest UK
business Outlook report from Accenture
and s p Global which suggests UK
business confidence rebounded in
February to its highest level in 12
months but joining me now is Rachel
Barton she is Accenture UK and Ireland
strategy and Consulting lead for Europe
Rachel welcome to you what's going on do
you think
good morning Ian and thank you for
having me on the show this latest
research indeed shows that the UK
business confidence has rebounded from
record lows in October to now a positive
43 this is the highest level we've seen
in the last 12 months it's double that
of the Eurozone and it's also amongst
the highest levels we're seeing globally
too
now there are some interesting
highlights I want to draw attention to
the first is that UK profit forecasts
have also turned positive for the first
time in a year the employment Outlook is
very strong particularly around
reskilling and all 14 of the sectors
surveyed are showing optimism including
Hospitality for the first time in 12
months so now it's key to turn that
positivity into action absolutely so I
mean there's confidence how is it going
to manifest itself presumably with
greater hiring and more business
investment
uh absolutely look it's really
encouraging to see renewed confidence
levels in the UK and you highlighted
earlier the latest data also shows that
we're seeing
um growth in the economy a very slight
growth that there are still headwinds of
course such as the continued cost of
living crisis
um concerns perhaps around a Resurgence
in Energy prices and so firms have
naturally looked to cost take out to
protect margins but cost takeout is not
the same as growth and now is time to
invest
so clients that I talk to are thinking
about investment in new technologies
like cloud data digital such as large
consumer goods organizations embarking
on digital manufacturing implementations
they're focusing on Talent particularly
around re-skilling and they're also
focusing on development of new products
and services and where they are green
that also can stimulate growth and new
investment
casting your mind ahead 24 hours then
Rachel would you expect or would you
hope that the chancellor is going to be
unveiling some fresh incentives for
business investment
well I can't speculate on what we're
going to see in the uh in the new
policies but um business will favor
anything that stimulates growth and
supports investment and if we can also
see any levels of green investment that
also helps the UK economy on the global
stage now you looked at business
investment more broadly as well I mean
it's it's improving everywhere but it
was striking that it's it seems to be
more rapidly growing in the UK than
elsewhere
yeah absolutely and it's um it's very
very encouraging that the UK confidence
levels are higher than Europe and the
global average and UK businesses have
demonstrated incredible resilience
during these challenging times and shown
themselves to be highly adaptable so we
can't lose sight of this optimism now
other economies across Europe are
perhaps more exposed to geopolitical
events or Energy prices if you look to
Germany for example very heavy
manufacturing sector impacts their
economy so um so it's important now for
the UK to seize the opportunity and
really start to invest to compete and
grow you mentioned the resilience of UK
businesses uh I wonder is it that we've
just got better at sort of navigating
these schools like higher energy prices
than some other uh countries
um we've seen very very strong
adaptability and versatility and you
think about what the UK has been through
over the last few years
um that resilience is starting to come
through what I would encourage and this
is where the UK perhaps wasn't as strong
as other European peers was around r d
Investments so research and
developmental capex spend we are still
seeing that caution come through and I
would really encourage that UK
businesses now not only think about how
they've been resilient and adaptable
when it comes to efficiency Automation
and cost take out but now show how that
resilience can drive growth
okay Rachel got to leave you there good
to see you this morning thank you thank
you
still to come here on Ian King live the
government's push for the UK to become a
world leader in Quantum Computing takes
another step forward don't go away
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
welcome back we've got a bit of breaking
news now concerning what we should refer
to as City Grandy's Sky City editor Mark
Kleinman can fill us in on the news Mark
what have you heard
yeah that's right in some fascinating
news from the city this morning which is
that sir Mike Reich a very prominent
City Grande who used to chair BT group
and EasyJet and was for a term uh
president of the CBI is joining one of
the world's most feared activist
investors now that activist investor is
Elliot advisors it's particularly
prominent at the moment because it's
involved in discussions about financing
a bid for Manchester United Football
Club but in the UK in London listed
companies it has invested in businesses
including Whitbread the owner of Premier
Inn Hotels uh glaxosmith climbed the
drug uh Giant and also it has taken a
stake in the past in BHP the mining
company now Elliott has a hostile
reputation in boardrooms around the
world including in the UK and I
understand that the appointment of
Semite rake is designed to soften that
image somewhat so Mike Will
engage with the boards of companies both
public and private in which only it
holds a stake and as I understand it his
appointment was finalized in the last
few days now Elliot in response to my
inquiry has given me a statement from
samite which says that he is delighted
to have been appointed as an adviser to
Elliot he has always admired Elliot's
track record and its commitment to
constructive engaged ownership in both
the private and public markets but this
is a fascinating sign-in of how activist
investors are having to soften their
images in order to gain Traction in the
boardrooms of the public companies in
particular in which they invest really
is very interesting development thanks
Mark
by Quantum Computing harnessing the
principles of quantum physics to perform
tasks and calculations more rapidly than
traditional computers has been
identified by Rishi sunak as one of the
fields along with artificial
intelligence and Life Sciences in which
he wants the UK to become a world leader
or one UK player in the sector is Oxford
Quantum circuits which today has
announced it seeking to make one of the
most powerful quantum computers
available commercially to businesses
worldwide well joining me now live from
Tokyo is Dr Ilana wisby founding chief
executive at Oxford Quantum circuits Dr
wisby welcome to you now this is in
partnership with the US company equinix
via one of its data centers in Tokyo
from where you're speaking to us why
there in particular
I think the the Japanese ecosystem has
been uh really thriving in Quantum and
there's such a huge amount of customers
that would be able to leverage this type
of technology so strategically it made
sense for us to set up both OKC KKK and
incorporate out here and but also to be
able to access
um the customers in Japan but also in
Asia more generally
Are you delivering the service in this
way rather than for example through the
cloud
um yeah so there's actually a number of
ways that you can access our systems
already so we can do private Cloud where
customers come directly to us we also
have public Cloud we're already
available on Amazon web services and
there's another cloud provider coming
soon but by being able to partner and
collaborate with equinix in this way we
can physically put oqc systems into the
data centers which is an existing secure
infrastructure and what we're really
excited about is the ability to then
direct interconnect with those customers
so they don't have to touch public Cloud
at all
and what are the typical applications
that you'd expect this to be used for
is this really a tremendous plethora of
applications across pretty much every
single Market vertical uh the way that
we tend to think about it is is two
separate ways so first of all is being
able to simulate so using Quantum to
simulate molecular systems or physical
systems for Advanced Materials Discovery
for new batteries Pharmaceuticals but
also the other side of it in processing
data there's a huge amount of data and
instead of being able to run algorithms
sequentially so for example if you
wanted to do a search of 1000 data sets
instead of having to do a thousand
searches with Quantum what you can
effectively do is walk into that room of
a thousand data sets and say hey which
one am I looking for and the natural
answer will produce itself which is a
lot more efficient a lot more effective
more time much more time efficient and
cost effective as well and and how do
you charge for for use of the facility
is it is it on a per use basis or do you
look to sign up subscript subscribers
yeah that's a great question so the
business model is actually something
that's also rapidly developing with the
um generation of the the new sector so
right now we operate through Quantum
compute as a service when a customer has
a problem that problem is translated to
an algorithm and that algorithm has what
we call many Gates or many steps
associated with it and typically you
charge per gate or per step
um actually this can become quite cost
intensive so what we're trying to do is
also reduce that cost and we can do that
and that's one of the things we will be
doing
um when making this system available
through our collaboration with equinix
enabled by the fact that we have some
very special core IP that means our
systems are actually more cost effective
for us to to run themselves and we also
seek to continue to develop and
different models we think we'll add more
to rewards a subscription type service
and we also run pocs as well which are
more Project based you mentioned your IP
there how long has this technology taken
to develop
oh well of course it leverages quantum
theory which is many many years old I
think from originally um Feynman first
postulated this stuff
um way back in the 70s but really the
technology has uh really started to
mature I would say in the last 10 years
and particularly in the commercial space
across the last five so Oxford Quantum
circuits and it originally span out from
the University of Oxford in June of 2017
and at that point in time we had a
patent from our professors research
group Dr Peter leak in Oxford University
and what we've then been able to do is
de-risk that technology within the
university environment and then spin it
out and now start to commercialize it
but the field really has accelerated and
both in technology maturity but also in
Market Readiness particularly across the
last three years
we have to leave it there doctor always
be very good to talk to you today thank
you for joining me
thank you
foreign
look at this morning's business Pages
now in the financial times you won't be
surprised to learn leads its print
edition with the right through of the
sell-off in banking stocks yesterday an
updated version of which is currently
leading its digital Edition but the Ft
also reports on its front page the
annual update to the basket of goods and
services used to track inflation by the
office for National statistics or outgo
non-film DVDs cooking apples digital
cameras and packets of 20 super king
size cigarettes while income video
doorbells security cameras and e-bikes
well the times leads its business pages
with the aftermath of Silicon Valley
Banks rescue but on the front page it
also carries a look ahead to tomorrow's
budget reporting that the chancellor
Jeremy hunts will raise the lifetime
allowance for pension Savers to a record
level to encourage people to keep
working or cuts to the lifetime
allowance by George Osborne have been
blamed for hastening the retirement of
doctors and other professionals the time
says the move will benefit nearly 2
million workers well that story is also
the Splash in the Daily Telegraph which
on its business Pages reports that
reactors powering the Next Generation
Australian Supreme submarines being
built under the orcas defense pact will
be built by Rolls-Royce to a British
design for joining me now is Jurgen
Meyer he's the industrialist and former
chief executive of course of Siemens UK
Jurgen good to see you this morning
obviously it's a budget day tomorrow a
couple of stories caught your eye in the
Ft the first of them Chancellor to offer
nearly 1 billion pounds for UK low tax
zones
indeed good morning uh uh Ian and uh
well uh it sounds it sounds very good
doesn't it that uh we're going to get
some stimulus to our uh Northern uh uh
economies and you know that I'm a fan of
stimulating growth through technology
and Industrial uh Industries
um and look what I'm reading here is a
dumb site better
um than what we had in the previous
budget uh with the
um list trust promising all sorts of
investment zones that weren't thought
through what I like about this is that
uh it's quite focused down on key
industrial uh sectors like life sciences
Advanced manufacturing and of course
green technologies
um the quantum Computing piece that you
just talked about I think being very
much part of that but look despite that
optimism there are two things here
um which it falls short of
um one is scale
despite the headline numbers when you
break it down per year Investments it's
not huge when you're competing with 300
billions worth of investment in the USA
for their similar plan the same in the
European Union and and evidence is that
we are losing out on investment and you
had a piece on early about confidence in
the UK increasing which is fantastic but
what we're still not seeing is the
increase in investment in r d in this
sort of deep technology like Quantum
Computing light green technologies and I
fear that this is not going to do quite
enough to encourage companies to really
invest in those fantastic areas here
versus uh in the European Union and the
USA I guess the government has to be
wary of accusations of trying to pick
winners
oh wow
um do you know my view is very clear on
this the government ends up picking more
winners by the fact that they don't have
an industrial strategy you know what
ends up happening you don't have an
industrial strategy to for example uh
support the transition to the electric
vehicle Revolution and because you don't
have that you then end up having to give
potential hands-outs to the likes of
Nissan and jaguar Land Rover who are now
saying we need some help because if you
don't give us it we're going to make our
batteries and our cars in Spain or
Austria or elsewhere and uh so so look
pick winners in terms of key
Technologies don't pick winners in terms
of individual companies
I always think back to Lord mandelson
the former business secretary said it
wasn't a case of picking winners it was
the losers who picked us
staying with another story you first
selected from the Ft here UK business
groups call on soon act to rejoin
Horizon Research scheme now this is
something that uh potentially looks
possible
yes and I really uh hope so and it sort
of links to what I was just talking
about we need to massively you know
increase the investment in key research
areas like Quantum Computing and the
many green technologies like uh like
hydrogen and uh and look we've had a a
northern Isle of like Northern Ireland
protocol uh deal done now which has
opened the doors to uh joining The
Horizon program every science
institution in the nation is saying we
want to join
um here you've got four business groups
the northern Powerhouse partnership that
I Vice chair make UK CBI and business
London Calling it yet you know
government is sort of dithering
um and I understand there's a
negotiation to be done we've not been in
it for two years but look I think the
message is here listen to the science
Community listen to business and just
get a deal done this is good for being a
science superpower
all right yeah can we go leave it there
I'm afraid good to catch up here this
morning thank you thank you
a bit of breaking news to bring you that
we've picked up in the last few moments
the UK competition Watchdog has wondered
as does deal worth around 600 million
pounds to buy co-ops petrol forecourse
could result in higher prices or less
choice for motorists and Shoppers in 13
locations the competition and Market
Authority opened an investigation into
the acquisition of 132 petrol stations
and adjoining shops in January Asda now
has five working days to offer proposal
to the regulator to help address its
concerns
now Britain's biggest 350 companies have
been set a new Target to increase the
ethnic diversity of their Senior
Management teams the Parker Review
Committee which was commissioned by the
business department in 2015 to consult
on the ethnic diversity of UK boards has
said that 96 out of the ftse 100
companies met the target with at least
one minority ethnic director on its
boards up from 89 last year it now wants
each footsie 350 company to set a
percentage Target for senior management
positions that will be occupied by
ethnic minority Executives in December
2027 and for the first time the Review
Committee is targeting 50 of the UK's
largest private companies they've been
set the target of having at least one
ethnic minority director on the main
board in that time as well I've been
speaking with David Tyler who chairs the
park review he's also chairman of Pisa
cousins the company behind Imperial
leather soap I began by asking him for a
reminder of why the review was set up in
the first place
would have set up back in 2015 when
Vince cable if you remember him was the
business secretary and he felt it was
important as did a lot of people in
business including herself to set
targets for ethnic diversity in boards
and indeed generally in in businesses
this was about five years after the
gender thing started I'm sure you've had
people talking about the women's uh uh
the the the the the progress of women in
the past in the studio and so that's
when it was set up for a very good
purpose
now according to the report today 10 of
senior board positions chairman chief
executive Chief Financial Officer are
now occupied by someone of an ethnic
minority group is that far enough for
you is that good enough for you well
what I'd say is it's a huge progress so
it's quite interesting those very
influential positions chairman and
executive directors the number in the
ftse hundred have gone up from 22 to 31
in the last year
sounds a small number but that's a lot
in a 31 you're you you've got 10 of
those overall influential positions so
in other words the uh ethnic minority
board members are not just being pointed
as non-executive directors they're in
these really influential positions and
that's encouraging is it enough no of
course we should be going further over
over a period I'm and I'm pretty sure we
are because the pipeline of people from
ethic minority backgrounds is growing
and getting more impressive in my
experience but also why more widely you
can see it in the statistics Yeah by uh
now there are four foot ftse 100
companies with no minority ethnic
representation on the board among them
unite frasers and foreign Colonial
Investment Trust did you get the sense
from many of those that they're looking
at this and they're taking this matter
seriously well we we don't uh name and
shame that's not not not our objective
it's up to them we think they're simply
making a mistake Ian because they're
missing out on that tremendous pool of
talent by not uh by not getting into it
uh I'm sure some of them will uh change
and and put ethnic minority directors on
on the board uh before before long but
what I would say is the fact that we now
have 96 out of the footsie hundred
having at least one ethnic minority
director and half of those have two or
more this is a sea change over the last
six or seven years when we started it
was only 47 so we've doubled the number
of uh of boards who have ethnic minority
directors so things are very different
around the board and I think that's
making better decisions emerge from
companies because of that now today
you've only targeted the top 350 quoted
companies very interestingly you now
want the 50 biggest private companies to
make some progress on this what's the
thinking there
they're very influential companies
they're huge companies they include you
know a lot of names that your viewers
would know extremely well big retailers
like John Lewis for example major
financial institutions like Nationwide
Health Providers like Bupa the big four
PWC Deloitte ey and KPMG some big
solicitors so big companies they are
influential in all sorts of ways uh
certainly for the economy but also on
society and it seemed to us that just
the same things hold for them as with
listed companies that they're likely to
do better if they have ethnic minority
representation and many many of them of
course already do
and not only that it will enhance
further the opportunities for people
from Financial ethnicities so we think
it's a win-win do you have though the
same leverage with private companies as
you do with plcs because obviously a lot
of institutional shareholders really
care about this and and they can
threaten sanctions on unquoted companies
there's no such sanctions with private
companies well not directly that's
certainly true though you know a lot of
companies have debt and debt investors
are also interested in this and they can
certainly persuade people by one means
or another but I think the important
point is not so much shareholders it's
employees
if I'm working for a company a private
company or a listed one and I'm for an
ethnic minority and I see they're not
really doing very much their targets are
rather low
I think I'm going to be poached by
another company much more likely also if
I'm someone thinking of going to that
company and joining it I might be put
off if they're not actually following
some of these um some of these sorts of
directions so I think this is what will
make most private companies want to
fulfill the sort of promises that we're
looking for them to do it's all
voluntary it's voluntary with listed
companies it's voluntary with private
companies but we think it's in their own
interests to bring stakeholders along
with them by doing these sorts of things
that was David Tyler speaking to me a
little earlier now wine production is
vital to the economy Argentina which is
among the world's top 10 wine exporters
but production fell by a fifth last year
so now the government is granting
producers a preferential Malbec dollar
exchange rate to try to boost exports
well Luigi Bosco which was founded more
than 120 years ago as one of Argentina's
leading wine producers it's been owned
and run for its entire existence by the
arutu family and its chief executive
Alberto arizu joins me now Alberto
welcome to you why was production down
so much last year now our production was
around 9.5 million bottles of wines and
we exported to 60 countries around
across the the world so we are the
production this year because we're in
harvesting now in 23 will reduce because
a big frost that we suffered last year
and the lack of water that reduce also
the Productions to 50 50 million King
mentors that is probably 30 percent less
than the average of the last 10 years so
how is this Malbec dollar going to help
well Maverick dollar definitely will
help uh to the to this sector in
particular we are suffering the higher
cost especially after the collapse of
the of the supply chain after the covet
situation we pay export taxis in
Argentina and the the the the the dollar
the the exchange rate is packed
artificially to the US dollar so a
differentiate uh dollar could help to
sustain and to maintain the
profitability of the sector and again
we've had other cost increases as well
for example corks corks bottles that
suffer a lot especially after the
collapse of the supply chains but also
the inflation now that the inflation is
affecting the whole world in Argentina
is another chapter because we have a
very high inflation and and my family
has been established in in Mendoza as
you mentioned for 120 years but the last
80 years Argentina has suffered High
inflation rates so we are navigating we
are we know about to navigate this kind
of sceneries now you mentioned you're in
60 countries which are the most
important export markets well definitely
we have four key markets uh us is one of
them it's probably the largest wine
consumer in the world uh UK is another
key market for us China and Brazil that
is very important Market because it's in
our back door in Argentina and who do
you think you're competing with is it
other New World producers or is it uh
the old world as well well it's a good
question because uh we consider part of
the old world because our history in
terms of the wine business remember that
all the colonies that came to Argentina
and the immigrants that they write to
Argentina and the last part of the 19th
century has been came from France Italy
France fans in Spain and and European
markets so we are a part of the old
world but we are in the new world and of
course your forebe has actually used
European vines that they planted in
Argentina yes especially the malvik
Malbec is French grape that my
great-grandparents and and their
immigrants they bring to Argentina many
years ago and find in Argentina at 10
above 1000 meters above sea level and
incredible conditions to produce very
high-end wines so we're very happy to
have the Malbec and we're celebrating
right now the the market were they very
exactly 17th of April I think it is yes
exactly now where you were involved in
Argentina's first designation of origin
appellation what has that done for sales
that was very important because uh
Malbec energy and you can cultivate
Malbec in all the country I mean from
the northern part to the southern part
and but malvik adapt in different soils
so that difference so we try to connect
the importance and to link the terrible
importance for the Malbec creating the
first appellation in the 90s so the
first wine was approved in 91 and was
our Luigi Bosca Malbec doc that is a
it's a very important Heritage of my
European
immigration character no but you don't
just produce mobile I mean you have some
very noted whites particularly Riesling
and Chardonnay yeah well in Argentina we
have a large sacrifice in the in the
slopes of the Andes Mountains in
different heights so we have four
thousand kilometers from the northern
part to the southern part so it is we
can we can produce all the grapes in a
wonderful conditions depending the
valets depending the composition of the
soil and depending the heads all right
fascinating talking to Alberto I could
talk to you all morning about it but
unfortunately we're out of time good to
see you this morning thank you